what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and yesterday we talked
about d23 because it is coming up this
saturday and also disney plus day is
coming up this thursday and yesterday we
talked a little bit about what to expect
from d23 but we primarily focused on
some trailers coming out and only talked
a tiny little bit about what to truly
expect from d23 this weekend i mentioned
that there are a lot of projects in
phase six that have not been announced
yet but i only talked about a few of
them so a few of you asked me well what
do i expect to actually be announced for
phase six at d23 and what do i expect
just in general that we will receive
from d23 so let's go over that today and
just like i did for san diego comic-con
we're going to talk about realistic
things to expect and then we'll talk
about things that are maybe a little bit
less likely but still could happen so
let's talk about what's likely to happen
less likely to happen and probably won't
happen and of course if you want to stay
up to date on all the news coming out
this weekend be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification bell now to start
off i'll briefly mention the trailers
that i mentioned yesterday i imagine
that we could be getting another trailer
for black panther wakanda forever
there's only two months until the movie
comes out so it's around that time where
they would release the official trailer
and this is a great time to do it then
the next full marvel film that we have
coming out is ant-man and the wasp
quantomania so if we were going to get a
new trailer for any film that is the
trailer that we are going to get and we
already did get a sneak peek at it at
san diego comic con although it was not
released to the public however the
trailer is complete we know that so it
is ready to go live to the public so
there is a possibility although this is
something that is not confirmed the
other thing is the guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 trailer is mostly finished
when they showed it at san diego
comic-con the cgi and graphics weren't
all done but it does appear like they
have the scenes that they want to put in
the trailer all edited out now this
isn't really likely if we are going to
get a trailer it's most likely going to
be for ant-man and of course some disney
plus shows however having said that i
think there is some footage that could
be shown at d23 like footage for the
marvels we know they have footage of the
film and at sdcc they showed us footage
of guardians 3 and ant-man and the wasp
quantomania and the marvels as the next
film to come out so there is always the
possibility that they could tease us
with footage from the marvels after all
they do need to tease footage at d23 it
is separate than sdcc so they still have
to tease things and make people really
excited and although if they do this it
won't be released to the public of
course people who are attending d23 are
able to describe what they saw so we'll
have a good description of what the
trailer is like now to get into a little
bit more exciting things like blade we
don't know much about blade right now we
just know mahershala ali is going to be
playing blade but i'm expecting him to
come on stage with kevin feige and i'm
expecting them to give us a little bit
of info about blade maybe our first look
at him in the actual outfit and maybe
even announce who the villain could
possibly be or at least the cast this is
a big one for marvel studios so i'm
expecting a little bit of time at least
focused on blade in fact i'm expecting a
little bit of time for the last six
projects of phase five i think they're
going to kind of divide their time i
think half of it is going to be spent
talking about phase five and half of it
is going to be spent revealing phase six
so that first half talking about phase
five i think most of that time is
actually going to be spent like i said
on the last six projects blade iron
heart agatha coven of chaos daredevil
born again captain america new world
order and the thunderbolts these were
simply announcements at sdcc the actors
didn't really come on stage they didn't
really talk too much about the film we
didn't really get any cast for them so i
think they're going to take this
opportunity to do that and give us a
little bit of information about these
upcoming projects now for the second
half marvel's phase six there are 11
projects for phase six and they have
only revealed three so i am expecting
and i do think it's very realistic to
expect marvel to reveal phase six in its
entirety or at least a good majority of
it after all they did give us all of
phase five at san diego comic con
however there were some projects a part
of phase 5 that were already revealed in
our case they have already revealed the
fantastic four avengers the king dynasty
and avengers secret wars now i talked a
little bit about this yesterday but i do
believe that they are going to give us
something for the fantastic four whether
that's a new director or maybe even some
of the cast the possible biggest reveal
for d23 could be the cast of the
fantastic four mr fantastic the
invisible woman the human torch and the
thing lately a lot of insiders have been
putting out names who marvel studios is
considering for the cast but i
personally believe that marvel might
already have their cast and if they do i
think this would be the perfect chance
to reveal it so fingers crossed but this
is not a guaranteed thing to happen it's
just a possible thing then i'm also
expecting to get a little bit of news
about the kang dynasty and secret wars
we already know that director of
shangchi dustin daniel [ __ ] is going
to be directing the kang dynasty they
will probably officially announce that
and maybe give us a little bit of
information about secret wars maybe even
who the villain could possibly be but as
far as those eight unreleased slots for
phase six go what could they possibly be
well fingers crossed that one of them is
going to be for a solo hulk project
rumors have been going around about
world war hulk for a while now and since
we've gotten everything from she-hulk it
does seem like that is very likely so if
that movie is coming up in the near
future and it looks like it is i would
expect that announcement and i would
expect a world war hulk type film to be
one of the slots for phase six next of
course is deadpool 3. we know deadpool
is coming and i am fully expecting an
announcement for deadpool 3 and ryan
reynolds to get up on stage at d23 in
fact i would be shocked if that didn't
happen now another one which is actually
kind of taking me by surprise and may
take other fans by surprise as well is
the possibility for a spider-man
announcement on the official poster for
this year's d23 there is a picture of
spider-man on it then on top of that
we've already seen banners for d23 for
this year that have spider-man on it as
well and this is really interesting
because sony has the rights to
spider-man but we know that kevin feige
has been working really closely with
them recently so maybe they got
permission to announce a new spider-man
movie at d23 after all it is the perfect
place and it's not like they're dropping
a trailer they're just doing an
announcement so fingers crossed for that
since we do have posters and banners it
looks like that could be a likely
possibility then of course we have nova
nova has been confirmed by deadline we
have just not yet received an official
announcement from anybody at marvel
studios yet but d23 is the perfect time
to do that and if it is already being
worked on and planned out that means it
should come in phase 6 so i am fully
expecting a nova announcement they could
even set them up in guardians of the
galaxy vol 3. now it's also been
confirmed by pretty much everybody but
marvel studios that a wonderman disney
plus show is in the works right now at
marvel studios so if that is true i'm
fully expecting a wonder man
announcement as well in fact this is
another one of those that i'd be shocked
if they didn't announce it another easy
one i think is armor wars we didn't see
it show up in phase 5 like we were
expecting however the team assured us
that armor wars is still coming well if
that's the case then it's probably
taking up one of the slots of phase six
i really doubt that they'd push it to
phase seven after the kang dynasty and
secret wars because you know roadie is
showing up for those now there's always
the possibility that they could announce
a shanxi 2 or an eternals 2 both of
those have been confirmed to be
happening we just don't really know when
if i had to guess i would assume that we
would get shang qi before the eternals
but of course the big one that everybody
wants to happen is an announcement for
the mutants this one is kind of up in
the air there have been a lot of
different reports from a lot of
different outlets stating that the
mutants are coming after secret wars
they're coming before but they're going
to be the fox x-men and some people
claim that marvel still doesn't have the
rights until 2025 so this is pretty
convoluted right now we don't really
know what is happening behind the scenes
at marvel studios but i would say if
they have everything in place and can do
a mutants project we are definitely
getting that in phase 6 before secret
wars and this would be the big
announcement and remember kevin feige
actually teased this at san diego comic
con in 2019 it's the last thing he said
he said we didn't even have time to talk
about the fantastic four or mutants well
he's already talked about the fantastic
four a lot so hopefully it's now time to
talk about the mutants and i gotta say
that would be a pretty big grand finale
an announcement about the mutants being
in the mcu now notice i didn't talk
about much disney plus stuff because
disney plus day is september 8th so i'm
assuming we'll get most of the
information then but if these projects
end up making up phase six will you be
happy with that or would you like
something to be a little bit different
let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you can stay
up to date on d23 this weekend for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof
you